I mean he got it you gotta be calculated
be Bendel's I think the planet they
heard that they had in the first movie
were you know star-lord just knocked him
out of whatever days he was I think that
same plant but you got a got to do it a
different way because he's ready for
that one again so we're my hands so I'll
get all the characters from like Cartoon
Network Nickelodeon Disney and then mess
them all together and then boom they
understand us
well you got all there's so many options
I mean like honestly like Doctor Strange
could do some stuff I would throw a
football on oh no the man is huge Chris
Pratt couldn't have messed up to
complete your fall the only way to
defeat Thanos is you got to take one of
his little rock thingies
so at the beginning of the movie I had
no idea was so important one of those
rocks was just at a train station in
like Scotland or something just bouncing
around nobody had a clue if that thing
was gonna end the world with one little
thing I think what you do need to do is
take cause these rocks and that's how
you win I think I would do sleight of
hand I think I'd steal it right from
them like a magician taking a watch and
that's how we would save the world Thor
could've had a better throw there's a
lot of things but now you make me sad
you know how they do like the fetal
position and I get something bigger and
balance going fetal position in hopes he
just takes mercy on ya
no one can beat him at this point I'm
not I'm not gonna start you know I do
have a mustache I got no job still
probably shooting we're gonna do the
easy route